we slowly starting to defrost here
in the Southern Hemisphere
which means our Father's Day
is right around the corner
and I'm planning on hosting a Father's Day brunch out here
but not while my patio looks like this
and I don't know if it's just cause emotionally
I'm really ready for some warmer weather
but lately I've been feeling that spring
cleaning energy possessing me
if you wanna give the father figure in your life
and not so subtle hint to get cleaning
might I suggest a Karcher for Father's Day
I highly recommend their range of water blasters
and also as someone who's renovating
another idea is the wet and dry vacuums
you can plug some power tools directly into it
so if you're sanding, for example
it will extract all of that dust
and bag it before it has a chance to get into
literally every corner of your house
and that one feature has saved my sanity
more than a few times
anyway it always horrifies me how filthy the
exterior of a house can get in winter
if you've been following along on our renovation journey
you'll know that this patio isn't even a year old
And surprisingly this isn't even the first time that I've cleaned it
but a side effect of being alive that they don't tell you
is the sheer amount of admin you'll have to do
just to stay on top of all of the jobs
but one thing I've learnt in my 33 years on this planet
is having the right tool for the job makes life so much easier
I cleaned the tiles with the paver attachment
and gave the furniture a once over
and now the space is looking brand new again
ready for some Father's Day festivities